all right make sure I got everything my
disposal here this is like a record for
me two guests in a row one of the
Thursday podcasts all right you ready
hey what's going on it's Bill Byrne it's
time for the Thursday afternoon just
before Friday Monday morning podcast and
I'm just checking in on you what's going
on how are you how's your week going
how's your week going that's wonderful
wonderful all right well once again two
weeks in a row
we we have a special guest in studio
this is the one and only comic legend
rich Scheibner who has a new book he's
here to plug that I actually got a
couple months ago but my wife is so
goddamn pregnant I've only been able to
read bits and pieces of it I read all of
I killed in 2006 he's got a book called
kicking through the ashes my life as a
stand-up in the 1980s comedy boom which
personally is my favorite era because I
watched all of it and that was and that
made me want to be a comedian and all
that's a rich welcome welcome to the
podcast
I got a ask so what year did you start
officially as a comedian because
everybody always has their yeah yeah
well I did two open mics and I went to
college first semester they always try
to delay when they stop I really will be
doing it six months here like [ __ ] 52
so when is your official January 77 Wow
yeah it's amazing to DC there are no
comedy clubs I was gonna say like where
was there to gig yeah it was a friend of
mine you know it was funny he said
you're funny you got to do this only
know if we knew it call it stand up he's
gonna take you down to we can do this
you know you could do it comedy at this
plane you were in law schools in law
school okay and and was a Iguana coffee
house it was just this basement in a
church you know under stall talent
nights right and I and I followed a poet
I saw the tape because my buddy I had
the tape at the tape audio video audio
just audio just a lot you know his big
black box cassettes like a shoebox size
cassette player right recorder and and
and the poet it is his last line was
like the mango we are ripe for the
revolution okay
you're looking a decade too late huh
wait ahead old mango nobody's talking
mango in Saudi sir
right but you're right way bide yeah the
Vietnam was over over love and he was
still trying to get that yeah yeah so
when you guys went that was what
fascinated back then because it's
because of you guys that there was a
comedy club your whole generation is the
reason why there's a comedy club scene
and I'm always like read stuff about Jay
Leno and it was just like yeah you need
to be like yeah I go down to the combat
zone which I weren't like the red light
district where Boston used to be and you
go on between like strippers anywhere
any break anywhere this guy Howard vine
who took me out first time he was like
my unofficial I found another place like
a talent night called a gay cabaret and
we were so weird we just felt like a
cabaret like The Flintstones this is 77
mean I can't be packed yeah yeah there
was money out of the closet except my
overpopulation pushed out you know right
so we could end there and it was you
know as a gay gay club and the guy was
right girl I say it fellas you know it's
a normally great soap and talent that
you know but uh this is this is ladies
night when once a month Ladies Day and
again we're so clueless we don't get it
we're like ladies like fantastic I still
don't get her what does that mean it was
lesbians bottoms
it was lesbians Oh bottoms yes ladies
night yeah Wow and I go out in front of
this lesbian crowd I mean date you know
I'm the reason they're there the high
get away from guys like me how did a
girl just a swing oh my god I mean you
know what I mean chill
I mean chill freezing cold I mean a
woman told me on stage finally just
clear I mean I got one light I did I was
I did like my buddy told me he said you
said like I guess I'm your worst
nightmare or something and got a kind of
a laugh but you know I thought oh that's
encouragement to do more instead of take
that as your exit yeah as a cue that we
we didn't come here for this
yeah you're done well and the woman just
walked up on stage took me by the arm
and led me off just beyond just like a
much had been I've had that you know
when I started out I had a gig and I I
didn't know it was a I didn't know was a
gay club I just got a gig the [ __ ]
guy didn't tell me the place was called
Queen of Hearts
what killed me was there's only a couple
of towns over from from where I lived
and like yeah and that was like still
the 80s early 90s that was still like
totally like
you know not accepted against Billy
Crystal's played moves like the only guy
played a gay character and that whole
thing just like went away so when I
found out I was all like parenthood my
trucks out there was all like homophobic
okay so I um I went there and I was
wearing my college like sweatshirt came
walking in like a 23 24 year old and I
walked by this guy I forget what the
hell he said he just said like oh my god
my fantasy is like that and that was
just like I was like wow that was really
forward so I went down to the end of the
bar and one of the women I was working
with that was like I'd walked in she was
hey Bill how you doing I said nice I
said guys hey that guy down the end of
the bargain he's a little happy she goes
what I got a guy I'd go down me on the
bar he goes I go he's a little happy and
she finally got she goes bill
everybody's a little happy here this is
a gay bar and then I looked around I was
like oh [ __ ] I was totally freaked the
[ __ ] out then you know by the time I get
the New York I was just like I you know
you start broadening horizons you don't
give a [ __ ] but huh so you started out
there so when I or what made it blow up
the way it did that all of a sudden
there was just you could you know and
instead of having to go on after a poet
or a stripper or whatever you had to do
like I was always interested like what
what like what years did all of us saw
these scenes started all these
independent like Boston had a comedy
scene right the ding ho you know those
guys there's right Lenny Clarke and
Barry Crimmins there was a scene up
there there was a scene Washington DC we
found this bar this guy started doing
comedy at this bar so Lewis Black myself
Kevin Rooney runs and all these guys
showed up to start doing stand-up his
little bar in Southeast Anacostia and it
was and the fact that was stand up
exclusively might say I'm like oh yeah
oh yeah it became packed immediately it
became like wild amita and there were
scene in San Francisco with the holy
city zoo and that comedy scene there was
one in Houston of comedy workshop with
Hicks and Kennison and those guys were
starting now did Elliott because I know
Dangerfield was around since like the
60s oh yeah
New York and LA actually they had seen
look I was doing it for like a year or
so and a friend of mine said she goes
you know there are comics like you're
doing this up in New York City I was
like what yeah they're comedy clothes so
she took me up there and I were you know
The Improv the comic strip and catch the
rising star but I didn't know about so I
went up there
so fasten because like there's no
internet there's no wonder no nobody
know anything like this guy comes in one
leg comes into el Brookman Slyke you
know Ram and he walks up to me he goes
hey I want to do a some stand-up
communist yeah at the end of the show we
like put guys on there no I'm a comic
out in San Francisco we're doing like
this out in San Francisco like what Jack
got place to Hawley's it he sue his name
was Tony to pawn he was running the holy
city so you tell me you got a crack here
man we're doing this out there too and I
was like what people are doing this you
didn't think like Ryan people are doing
it we're just doing it and you don't
know nobody's talking there's a scene in
Philly there were about six or seven
cities add scenes percolating
percolating so how did those guys back
in the day like if they had to do way
back to like Ed Sullivan like how did
you put your set together I know this
guy's did Vegas and they did casinos I
guess you just had to be based in New
York or LA to get stage time to actually
yeah but those guys they but they didn't
there were places all over they were you
know the the nightclubs started
happening right after World War one when
like was not four clubs right right they
started doing the speakeasy know when
when prohibition came in so the comics
moved in out of vaudeville started
moving into these nightclubs to make
real money right that's where it started
so they're always you know back in the
fifties and sixties they call them the
toilets where these guys were trained
you know the guys you gotta work the
toilets a little little bar out in
Jersey tow did a little comedy a little
show he'd be part of a show you know
there's a singer and dancer right right
it was an exclusively comedy thing for
Dangerfield's wasn't exclusively
stand-up you know dangerous had the
singers and stand-ups and also they were
at the piano they haven't changed so
what year did so then I guess imagine is
the supper club started to go away then
your guys seen then created that seeded
comedy club that's right - no my
generation they were going out to the
dinner clubs you know going out and have
a dinner and see a show nobody was doing
anymore that was out you know he's
already does old people's stuff so we
were in rock concerts so then that kind
of like started fading right you know
you're gonna get a little older you
wanted a his can't go date you know so
everybody's kind of looking for the next
thing
and it happened like some guy opens up a
comedy club you know there's the three
paying comedy clubs out here in the late
70s in California there was mitts he
opened a place down in Pacific Beach 76
had moved over into La Jolla 77th and
there was a
they're gonna guy mike callie open up
place the laughs stopped out of Newport
preaching and Mike Lacey which you been
out of the comedy magic now down our
most beats in 78 there were a first
three paying like paying they bring
comics in from LA and pay him a couple
hundred bucks Wow
and then Garvin's in Washington DC open
in 79 January 79 start paying comics
from New York to come down and do it so
at this point you've been doing it like
two years or two years and I became the
MC there that's why I met orders comics
I started working with Seinfeld and Bill
Maher and Overton ok what time at what
point did you did you start to sense
like wow man like I sort of jumped into
this thing that has just taken off like
what point did it really seem like like
this like the sky's the limit it's
almost like a real estate boom yeah yeah
I didn't you know it did until we wha me
sucked in it we were making money you
know like the comic strip in Fort
Lauderdale opened like January or so 80
and remember going down there and I'm
working with my first wife Carol Leifer
and Joe bolster and mark Schiff and
Kelly Rogers and and Kelly pulls me over
in a comedy condo right that the first
comedy condo so it's it's clean it's a
phone inside got a phone and he goes
cakes up the party just come here come
here anyways whatever this guy says you
can do tell him you can do it if you ask
whatever yes Tony you can do it second
the phone guy use hey I just open up
this club in Ottawa Canada I need a guy
can go due to 45 minutes sets can you do
two separate 45-minute shows at all yet
Jesus Christ I hang up the phone ago
Kelly I got like a half after they buy
everything yeah they take everything I'm
killing right I'm killing everything he
says don't worry you'll do it go do it
so I go up there I do two-week right you
know if my strategy was do all why
didn't you need to cuz he's the same
crowd he didn't it was a big bar it was
just a big parties with comedy rooms at
first wasn't like they set up oh we're
gonna be you know we're open up a new
club we're gonna build this club they
just there was a rock bar he wasn't
getting a lot of business in Rock bar I
don't know he get the ideas I'm gonna do
comedy right so once twice a month he
was doing comedy
probably comedian it so I guess what
happened cuz they don't really pay
attention to how long you're up there is
just how well you're doing did you pull
up short on your sets or did you do you
think I was counting back there man I
know I'm drinking shot something I'm
trying to come up with dub smoking weed
between the sets trying to come up with
new you know
up there doing whatever I can do to try
to you know I mean I did all the
material I could do I had up front and
then just ran around the room like Jerry
Lewis you know like I was out of my mind
wow you know did you save a bit for the
end to close thoughts of that David bit
let me call that closer opener it's like
just funny and a hold just hold the
stage and and you pulled it off I pull
it off so yet in the week the guy goes
he's paying me cuz this was great man
it's like a weekend you know like three
days or something he said guys on the
phone wants to talk pick up the phone
this guy goes like I got a club in
Montreal I heard you're great you want
to come down here come win now come on
Dover just come over now
and I did the next week in Montreux and
then he puts me on the phone with with
Mark from Yuk Yuk's Breslin Mark Breslin
from Yuk Yuk's same thing I want right
the Breslin in Toronto so I went out
there that I did like you know three
weeks in a row it came back I'm a
headliner I thought I'm a headliner well
I didn't know what it was but was that
two three years in I was yeah it was
like in 1980 so I'm like three years in
so I was open up for a lot of rock bands
I that was it at that point you could
quit your day job I didn't have a day
job
my last yeah my last day job was ya bout
then because I was my last day job was
working in New York City I was cleaning
out apartments for the mob I didn't know
that's what I was doing but that's what
I was doing cleaning them out water all
down down down to him down ax got shot
in the [ __ ] truck what would you this
you know I remember this but 77 on that
Arab my my first apartment a base wasn't
even real apartment which is have some
wall syrup it was every other building
was abandoned squatters everywhere only
that someone's out easily bankrupt right
he's bankrupt De Niro in taxi
era exactly so they started selling
buildings for a buck
but you had to promise the rehab the
building within a year they're turning
into a rental proper right so they're
ten dollars so I'm not gonna be set for
well you had to fix him right right you
had to fix him up so I'm having a hard
time paying the rents the landlord is a
man you do carpet you work not like oh
yeah yeah I can do carpentry work he
says in order to help these guys are how
much of your life has been like yeah I
can do that
they just [ __ ] showing up and running
around like Jerry Lewis
that's amazing so you say yeah then I go
over there these guys in New York guys
they figure out in three seconds I can't
really do carpentry but they um I'm an
okay guy you know get some cigarettes
and beer go get some cigarettes and beer
for us you know go do this go do that
you know I'll go for four right so the
end of the day yeah you can't do car
Bertie but can you clean out apartment I
go well yeah I can you know my family
they can tell you our manual labor man
that's that's how we stay on the planet
manual labor right so I show up the next
morning there's three young Italian guys
I leave that there stand outside of
building or passing around a half point
they go hey ready yeah I'm a new guy
yeah yeah okay let's go we're throwing
squatters out we're cleaning out
apartments Oh God we're throwing people
out of apartments you know we're going
in with we're going in a shooting
galleries man people are shooting up or
throwing stuff out the windows with our
hustling people apps well [ __ ] five
bucks break 5 bucks an hour under the
table 5 bucks throw people out on the
street I'll break down the whole emotion
of that you walk up to the door is it
unlocked is it long you walk up the door
and and I'd been in a squatter place
when I first moved up there so I kind of
understood it you know but you see it
like extension cables running him from
building a building they were you know
they're stealing I don't know how far to
back up with your life so how the [ __ ]
do you so you go up there you little
water building I when I first how does
that go down that was that was 74 when I
fought the New York and 74 bad no plan
and you had no money and then you'll see
an abandoned building you walk there's
other people in there your guy guy was
like escape from New York people
crawling up on a manhole yeah people
were people they'd get a building they
don't they put you seed locks when
outside of the door there were no locks
like a key lock oh my god we have a
padlock you know a padlock right that's
how he got in and get out and then he'd
lock the inside they have bolts and lock
the inside and they'd have electricity
stealing from one building nor another
building whatever they're running cables
in some places that no electricity
they were just I'm sure that wasn't a
fire hazard I know there's some guy that
actually could be working as an
electrician but it's deciding to live
for free
in this [ __ ] building if people are
fascinated yeah all right so night night
you now you're on the other side okay
the [ __ ] student has become the
master now you're gonna throw someone
out like yourself as anyone on drugs but
so what what was that it's Ryan
screaming frightened unless so no people
were like okay cool cuz they've got
notice
like surprised they'd ignore notices put
those this building as a vault and you
got to leave evacuate you know get out
whatever it is and they were ignoring it
or they and so some people cool okay
we're going
some people they kicked in doors we go
running in we thrown their stuff out the
windows right it was well where there's
so many abandoned buildings in the [ __ ]
it I'll just grab my [ __ ] and just go
down the street and around the corner
I'll have another one yeah I don't know
what the route of to was I mean I didn't
really care I mean it was pretty hectic
it was pretty did you have to physically
there were a couple times we had to like
you know fight off people or push him
around but you guys are us these guys
were rough they were young and rough man
okay did they have the Joe Pesci [ __ ] no
they were they were dry you know they
were dressed and ready for business the
three-quarter leather that every
jerk-off like me
war and I was not that guy man wow
that's [ __ ] amazing so I don't want
to spend too much in your past because
we're here to uh I mean we're definitely
gonna go back because I'm a geek for all
of this [ __ ] but let's talk about the
presence here you're kicking through the
ashes let the parts that I read what I
loved about it is you you do not
sugarcoat anything like the what
happened the odds of you making it
anything it was really kind of like like
you just kind of laid it out there yeah
like how do I'm I know you've done books
in the past and and stuff and how did
this whole thing like I mean it had to
be through just telling stories of guys
like me knowing how interested I am in
this [ __ ] you know you tell you sores
for years you tell these stories and
sometimes I hear strays come back and go
well that's just that's my story that's
not how it went
yeah you tell my story or whatever like
the Olly joke Raiders story I'd hear
stories like that the coming by that one
cuz I've always seen his now he's now
full you guys listening he's a legendary
comic from the comedy story I believe at
a cowboy hat in the beer he was right he
was doing the glare 'ti cable guy sort
of country-western comic before you know
and I always read his first name is oily
cuz I had like a learning disability or
I'm just a [ __ ] and then someone
finally said the name like oh [ __ ]
that's how you say his name so that guy
Gilbert Hertzog was his real name
Gilbert hurt Hartsock heart song and he
went by Ali Joe Prater Hali Joe pretty
looked like you're somebody Sammy's a
shirt guy was heavy yet cowboy
boots a cowboy hat you know he looked
like a cartoon character right and he
was a classic seat back when these clubs
started popping the places were packed
they didn't need guys to draw they had
packed they wanted guys to sell alcohol
we were liquor pimps you know who sold
the most and I like Joe would drink on
stage and what a crowd would drink with
him
what would they pay you guys back then
to have started escalating fast
I mean you first glad to go you know
it's eight hundred bucks a week and then
what you back we let you back when he
till the club's want you so these will
pay look twice was that went up by about
400 bucks 20 years later when I started
that's what I loved in New York one way
we almost had that strike it was like it
was 50 bucks for a weekend spot for like
20 30 years 50 bucks 50 bucks and
everything else up all the Caloris
multi-millionaires and finally were like
what the [ __ ] and we asked for a hundred
just knowing that we get like 75 and it
completely freaked out but uh anyways
getting paralyzed so de-escalating fast
but but but guys like I like Joe word
you know he was of real he's sold there
you come in they go
Holly Joe just saw like thirteen
thousand dollars worth of liquor last
week and what was his that was it sort
of you see he was like you know a buyer
bought that you would it Larry the Cable
Guy Foxworthy know he was will oh he was
and he was you know he would chug a beer
I he'd start his act by just like
chugging a beer and on and then he belch
and you know that's everything I learned
in college oh Jesus so he set the tone
early he said I would not want to follow
that guy today he he was and he and he
would literally took anybody's act
there's an old line I don't know whose
line this was but somebody won says if
Ally Joe came up and bought your beer
that means he just did one of your jokes
lolly joe shared a joint with you he did
a couple years oaks if I like Joe laid
out a line of coke for you you just
played Cleveland yeah and I did seem
like back then like certainly through
like vaudeville like people just taking
other people's [ __ ] was always seemed
annoying but like it wasn't like the way
it is now or it's just like so it's like
I know post 9/11 like why are you being
hostile like I remember seeing George
Burns one time on 60 minutes or
something and he said you know I used to
do this bit blah blah blah blah blah
you know he tells the joke he goes you
know you know it's he goes in I mean
it's not a great joke I don't think
Milty would steal it and like he threw
that out there on TV and years and I was
just thinking like I was just ribbing
and then years later when I became a
comedian I was just like wow like he
really meant something by that and that
guy must have been you know at least
[ __ ] with his act on some level that
if he said that George Burns is on 60
minutes and [ __ ] call somebody out
for taking his [ __ ] so yeah but it
didn't matter to him like that does now
she did not see the Milton Owen that it
used to calm the thief of bad gags he
owned it he did like he was like I
didn't steal this when I stole that one
or they didn't care like we did Brian
you know if they did worry about
stealing her acts back in vaudeville
they used to the only way to like
prevent it was they would pay stagehands
to protect their acts so if you came in
and I just played there and then you
came in you started doing my bits
sandbag drops near you oh like give you
a warning you know they get like a heavy
warning but then see that Ariat you
could get away with before cell phone
cameras and stuff you completely
deliberately drop it on the guy's head
he dies now we know what happened we
have a [ __ ] underneath the stage Wow
changed in Lenny Bruce's time see before
that the comics were just kind of stick
you know and so you doing some stick and
that people were buying jokes and
selling jokes and they were a pretty
intern from California boy am i arms
tired it was install [ __ ] like that yeah
it didn't matter it so when Lenny and
those guys try to make him what the
comic said was important it became
artful and it mattered and you became
tied to material so like what you said
mattered and people wanted to believe
that that was really you
Brian's really your opinion that was
really your life then it mattered then
you started taking things and it
mattered okay so when you come along I
mean that's that's 25 years after Lenny
Bruce what the thing that it didn't
matter with you guys was because there's
no YouTube there's none of that [ __ ] and
you guys are just going up after poets
and strippers and stuff so yeah once I
got to just go up and survive or yeah
but once that [ __ ] got into business
it mattered
it started matter but there was so few
comics we could place the community
ourselves right that's the difference
you know like a guy became a thief he
doesn't get to work the clubs he doesn't
get the work that the a room's it was
like when I start when I started in
Boston dude if you if you went over your
time
you went over your time and by over your
time like it but you know we told you to
do 25 minutes you did 28 28 like you
were in the [ __ ] doghouse like dude
what the you did three extra minutes
like like it was such a huge thing and
forget about stealing jokes like I'm so
fortunate that I started in Boston and
all those ding ho guys like so set the
bar so high that if you are any hack if
you any like derivative they let you go
for like two three years you're okay
you're influenced by Gavin Sweeney or
noxee or something but then after that
it was just like dude you need to come
up with your own [ __ ] in but and it was
one of those things like Boston's an
unforgiving place so it's just like once
you were labeled you were you had to
leave so see that's it that's it you got
trained you got trained there's nobody
doing the training anymore but you got
trained and that's how they did in
vaudeville - the same sort of things man
they trained you they trained you guys
would be coming up that you have to
learn to do it the right way or you
wouldn't get any time what was the first
like real comedy club like like you know
going up to Ottawa but like you you
weren't you felt like like when did all
like those a rooms start coming up like
the punch lines the money start around
82 they all start there there's some
great rooms as started a lot of these
rooms they started at that man wrote in
the book there's one like you go you
were after Minneapolis to play a room
I'm gonna play a place called Mickey
Finn's now these rooms rejected just to
them together so I get out there and you
know I felt like the gunslinger I come
into town I'm like one of the first
actually bring in I'm from New York I
see all those guys Jeff Caesarea Louie
Anderson they're all standing in the
back while Bill Bauer or stand in the
back I said that new there's a local
comics there don't guys we're all from
from Minnesota yeah they're all state I
see I could see him you get pin you go
there they are there they are they're
here to check me out right I'm gonna hit
that stage man I'm gonna know I'm here
man I'm gonna rub there man I'm gonna
rock star right side and checked
anything out so I go running up and jump
on the stage the stage was just a bunch
of milk cartons right real crates with a
sheet of plywood on top God so I go for
I just surfed the whole thing the whole
thing just takes off I just go flying it
blow to a couple tables hit the wall
partially separate my shoulder jump up
like probably the biggest laugh you got
that right there like everybody's laugh
like a put the stage back in place and I
did my set oh my god
so well now who else was a part of that
Minneapolis scene that was a big names
to say yeah Anderson yeah yeah you've
been watching Louie on Zach oh yeah he's
great
that's what I love about comedy is this
sometimes is like dude you should do
something with this person but who would
ever would have thought that we should
play Zach's dad and Zach was a went to
Clown College in France and ends up in
Bakersfield California I was talking to
my wife about that last night we were
laying in bed room then the commercial
came on for it and they're just like
this [ __ ] like perfect casting
together going like whoo to have a thick
night that's it yeah in the way that did
they go back and forth it's like they've
been working together for like 50 years
like an old comedy team and now that's
one of the things one of my favorite
things as like because I despite how
long I've been in this business I've
always just I've maintained that whole
nerd sort of huge fan of of stuff like
that so who is a guy that when you was
in the early 80s like you know there's
always those guys that you know when you
start out you just like there's no
[ __ ] way this person this person
doesn't make it nobody's gonna make it
like those guys that you could be the
worst manager in a world and you knew
that's almost gonna make it do you
remember seen anybody like that well you
knew this is you know thought guys don't
realize it but you do look back you go
like Leno you hear Jay Leno the first
time I saw him I go this guy's a killer
I've always heard that Aries I mean just
destroyed rooms
he had the belt for like what yeah 15
years yeah oh yeah actually before he
had to do the Tonight Show every night
yeah I mean you know I'd go into clubs
and I'd be like I'd go in first thing
I'd say is who's got the record who's
got the time
you know who's done the longest tear hey
this guy clean her stood out at 45 it's
done tonight it's over tonight you know
I'm doing too easy you know and I go gun
him for everybody and they're not going
into town and after Leno's started
working at clubs right when he started
doing Letterman start popping big you
couldn't go who's got the I Jay Leno
just did three hours yeah three hours
would you lock the doors like vogner and
opera what'd he do hold the audience in
it no I had four ovations they brought
him back four times that's and he still
had the materials that's what's always
blowing my mind about those people like
that was a period where people trying to
like set the record and they're going
into stage for like seven eight nine
hours I was just always picturing like
eight hours in
with chairs you know it just like how do
you still have yeah yeah at that point
it's just like you're just not getting
down now that that's yeah that's world
we might as well you sitting on a
[ __ ] flagpole exactly what kills me
is somebody actually sat there and
watched all then there's a [ __ ] you
know two people left from the waitstaff
that have to stay there ah no this was
but this was legit show this is legit
show cuz people were drinking and doing
coke and they had they the crowd could
hang right this is legit this Board of
drunk driving laws change this is all
different what class were you from as
far as like so you I know you were in
New York how long were you in New York
Belzer was the king of New York stand-up
comedy back then yeah he was I mean you
see him work that room catch he just
owned it you know he said he just set
the record for playing like a TV
character for the longest time on a show
or something like that really he said
something I remember being a Knicks
comedy stop and the early 90s and he was
headlining and he was going yeah you
know they want me to do this this
procedural show or something like that
you know what you think you should I do
it should I do it I remember sitting in
the back club going the [ __ ] is this guy
asses of course you're gonna do it
should I be on TV absolutely I didn't
realize how much money he was making as
a comedian but like it's kind of cool
that I remember reading that like within
like the last like a few weeks that he
just set some [ __ ] record for playing
the same guy in the same show since
basically my entire stand-up career like
almost 25 Wow been that long yeah so you
were yeah he was the guy Gilbert
Gottfried I saw when he you saw him we
were like that day he's the guy I mean I
when I once watched him too many nights
in row and went down that East River and
burned all my material burned on my
notebooks out she burned them all I said
I'm just hack I've always told this
story I'm on my favorite ones I ever saw
him he went up at Nick's comedy stuff
one time in front of a bunch of [ __ ]
drunk boston morons and they were not
getting him and he didn't waver at all
he did his [ __ ] he had this little old
man yellow sweater on and I remember one
of his jokes cuz all the comics were
dying laugh and he was just vomiting
from this crowd and he goes you know I
went to a party the other night and I
ran into Jackie Onassis and I said
Jackie do you remember where your work
and we're all dying laughing and nobody
got it nobody got the joke and then he
would just go on to the next one and do
[ __ ] dead like silence and he toughed
his way through that but uh first time I
saw him I wasn't in the business was I
saw him in one of the Beverly Hills cops
movies you weren't a Beverly Hills Cop
oh yeah what was that like hey you know
it's funny meaning I think I film for
like four days for five seconds of
screen time a couple of how it works and
it was fun was hanging out you know it
was that time when I saw wow this is the
star Eddie Eddie Murphy there was a
scene where they're going all right
Eddie we got a hold on man we got to
change some lighting and I guess I'm
ready goes yeah but the director said
hold on we'll get some it said he goes
and he goes come on let's go so he goes
grabs it like a bag of bread off the
craft table and we go down to the putts
at the Playboy Mansion so we just go
down he starts feeding the geese we're
just throwing bread to him so about five
ten minutes later one of the 80s comes
there's Eddie they're ready for you now
and he just said even turn around just
keeps eating at the feeding of the geese
hey Eddie we're ready we're ready he
does ignores them they leave to come
back five minutes later Eddie were you
ready now and he's just he made him wait
they made him wait he made him wait well
I I said that's I go that's power that's
that you know he's like the [ __ ]
balls oh yeah yeah hat in hand yeah I
all never get no I've never understood
like people that uh what's what's funny
and tragic is watching people pulling
those moves when they don't have the
power which I've seen a lot see
especially now where so many aspects of
the entertainment built business because
of the internet have just gone down the
[ __ ] like the entire music business you
know anybody nowadays who complains
where's all the good music girl sucks I
always go well you get what you pay for
I'm guilty of it too I spy scope I climb
wired a lot of [ __ ] I live yeah a couple
of [ __ ] laptops that he's got the
virus out before somebody finally went
like dude you're in this business you
should pay for like I might have been
Russman Eve in New York said that to me
and I haven't I haven't illegally
downloaded a song or anything in like a
dozen years way back to like Napster
LimeWire was the last one that I use
but anyways yeah I've seen people like
try to pull that do you know who I am
and all of that and the people who do
that now it's just like dude you are not
paying attention to this business we're
like remember like back in the day to
try to get if they got like two major
stars in a movie it was just like holy
[ __ ] this is gonna be like a blockbuster
forget about now we're like every movie
is like Ocean's eleven like like
everybody got just bumped down like like
like this [ __ ] that I would go in and
audition for in like the 90s you'll have
now a guy who like used to star in
[ __ ] movies like be level movie is
going and taking that spot all these
stars are on TV and you just see these
people pulling their moves but um that
they I can't I mean that happens on a
movie set like it like the lighting
isn't right it's a lot of waiting around
I mean there's an entire crew film crew
there people all over they had you know
the scene was they were gonna shoot
Eddie just walking past a bunch of women
playing volleyball in bikinis right
right so we get up to the scene and they
start doing it and the directors yawn he
goes
jump higher girls jump higher you know
jump higher he's trying to get jiggle
going and I see I go to Eddie go there's
too much DuPont out there manager goes
what that he goes he tells what I said
director Lee alright let's shoot the
scene forget it it's all silicon man
ain't no jiggling happen now how was
Eddie handling uh I mean did you know
Eddie before yeah I know him from back
in New York and the day I mean the first
time he came in the improv I was I was
the emcee on Sunday night I was like the
regular when I was in town I was when I
was down in like 46 or 45th street on
the west side it was on 44th 44 and
ninth right right there yeah okay I used
to live in that neighborhood right and
we used to go down and uh I read this
whole thing I might have been you know
something I heard from you or something
and it's now it's like it's a pizza
place or something and that's why
Richard Pryor that really raw video of
him just standing when he was stopped
being the Bill Cosby clone right and he
was turned into rich like he literally
was turning in to Richard Pryor the
greatest of all time and like that
always blew my mind that that was within
like 15 blocks of where I lived and I
would go in there and get the pizza the
pizza was only okay
but I just wanted to be like so like see
that wall we're just wondering where the
[ __ ] stage was yeah can i as a total
geek question when you walked into that
because it's basically the same space
right where was the stage walk in the
stage is all in the back of the room
there was a there was an emergency door
exit right by the stage and the stage is
a little you know what's it all one room
there was no walls he wasn't there's one
room there's a bar there's there's a bar
out there everybody hung out in a bar
does a good bar a cool bar everybody
hung out there and then you'd walk
through this little narrow little narrow
hallway but short you know and the men's
bathroom was on the right-hand side of
literally like a toilet and a sink you
know like a one of those little closets
right and then you'd walk in this little
hall and the light was right there like
by the service bar so if you're on stage
and you see Rodney come under that light
you know you go Dangerfield's here got
to get off got to get Rodney on quick
he's making the rounds getting ready to
do a Tonight Show or something so you
see people pop up into that light area
probably see his [ __ ] silhouette -
and you know who he was oh yeah you just
see him you just see me just he'd pop
any Mitsu's you saw him he'd pop out and
you know get on and I ride I was like
because I saw Rodney when I was on stage
I'd cut mid joke you know and then hey
we got a special guest here
[Music]
I remember going off and Rodney coming
on because hey you know how to [ __ ]
move the kid that has a move and he
moves he goes on a move that's awesome
that you know like that I just reminded
me one time I did have I did a benefit
at this theater in a beacon beacon
theatres I forgot the hell did goddamn
benefit was where was a sickest lineup I
was ever on it was Jon Stewart was
hosting Max Weinberg brought his band
Tony Bennett goes on first then Bruce
Springsteen then they auctioned off one
of his guitars to this rich crowd that
goes for like a hundred grand then
[ __ ] Joel McHale had to follow that
like I know my kales got he has to have
that I followed [ __ ] Satori and then
I went up after him which you know he
was the total buffer to get it back to
you all right settle down and
expectations this is what you paid for
here right and Seinfeld was closing that
was the lineup and
I remember when I was doing my set I was
conscious about not being too dirty
because I mean Seinfeld's like
King and I remember looking over I was
getting close to the end of my set and
he was standing on the side of the the
stage and you know the light was behind
so he was like backlit and I knew who he
was with his silhouette like that's how
famous this guy is and to me and it
wasn't just Jerry hanging out he had the
suit on it was Jerry ready to go to work
and I was immediately thinking like oh
my god am I being too blue is he gonna
hate me am i pissing him off am I going
over mmm and I remember when I got
offstage he went like I walked by him I
was just and I was just I was almost
afraid to say hello I just like walked
by and he's went very funny very funny
and then I apologize for working you
know the way I do I said oh sorry of a
bob line because I don't care don't give
a [ __ ] and I'm thinking like that's
right this guy always worked clean and
he worked clean before there was even
comedy clubs so I can't imagine him
going on after these guys who would chug
a beer and then burp and be like that's
what I learned in college and like that
sort of energy is fun but it whips him
into like this front frat boy yinz yeah
and then you got to go up there and if
you have like a more of a you know just
straight-laced kind of like yeah I mean
I have a beer every once in a while but
guys like I'm not letting this totally
affect my life you know well I love the
fact that you did that that's the
training got in Boston ago I'm part of
the show I know I'm not closing so I'm
gonna respect the headliner oh yeah how
it works yo that was another that was
another way that you would get you would
get blackballed I remember there was a
comedian up there Mike Donovan you ever
work with them I know who you're [ __ ]
hilarious guy and he used to always say
this thing was hilarious
and he'd be like it'd be like yeah just
got there you know do like 20 minutes
you know to keep it like you know three
or five bucks is what do you say he
wasn't bullshitting he was like people
in Boston counted the [ __ ] so I
remember you know sometimes going over
it and being in a panic like oh my god
that was my sixth [ __ ] Donovan's gonna
call Mike Clark and I'm gonna be I'm
gonna be ruined in this town I said [ __ ]
six times so
I mean I don't want to sit there and be
like the old guys in just because I
don't know what it is like for kids
coming up now in mine yes kids to me now
or anyone up to like 32 33
coming up now but I'm sure that they
have their their whole way that they
don't always change it but I like that
but you know cipher always had that
discipline I remember working with him
in these Jersey kicks like Jersey gigs
like $55 Jersey Jesus started there like
the first paying gigs we could get go
out the juries in some bar right and so
you know it's survival time in a bar so
a lot of guys would be like what I got
to do to get by you know yeah it was a
crowd Jed dick jokes when I got do to
get good night
right and I remember working with Jerry
one time and he goes on and he'd follow
all that and he stays right - he's doing
man works clean brings him to him but no
but he wasn't killing it does not like
at all they don't came to him they were
like oh wait the party's over it wasn't
great but he never broke he never
wavered and I have to go wow man he goes
I'm getting ready to do tonight shows
that's what I'm preparing to do he had
the focus had the long-range focus he
was like I'm practicing this material
here now cuz I'm gonna do this on The
Tonight Show I'm working this out now
I'm not worried about my $55 Jersey he's
one of those guys long-range view yeah
he's one of those guys that he just
[ __ ] knew were you ID yeah he just
knew where he was going and he just like
you'll never meet a guy that doesn't
suffer fools the way he does I still
when I get around him I getting nervous
I'm where I'm gonna say one stupid thing
and this guy's gonna I'm gonna get that
look and that's just gonna be he'll try
to walk away the same way like his act
is the way he lives his life there's no
fat
yeah there's no extra word or any of
that type of [ __ ] and I just [ __ ]
just like he just walks towards what he
wants walks right through I mean I got a
malicious no I just like he just I own
the [ __ ] prize that guy you know back
in the day guys would go like you know
what I'm like is that cuz you don't
really know who he is up there go are
you [ __ ] paying attention yeah you
know exactly you know what pissed this
guy off the missus sucking a [ __ ]
dryer yeah that's who he is man I just
paid attention he's [ __ ] paying
attention to the details that's what's
irritating this guy I did his web series
one time and I told him that I told him
oh I hated that they said his show is a
show about nothing it's like no it isn't
this guy has content
for 90% of people and activities I was
actually nervous saying it to him and he
laughed and it was I think you're being
generous by saying it you know that it's
only 90 percent yeah that's so [ __ ]
cool so when did like oh god there's so
many things I want to ask you this is
far so The Improv The Improv started in
New York City and then they opened the
LA one right good they open the LA one
because he realized everything was
moving out to LA when Johnny moved with
Carson moved that was that time when he
moved in 72 the whole thing shifted the
axis shifted right everybody had to go
out to LA and the Comedy Store just
opened then so al Comedy Store became
people going on on The Tonight Show
going yeah I work out The Comedy Store
in LA that became the place Wow right so
buddy's like I got to get out there yeah
and then the home because he wasn't
getting the brand recognition and no he
was getting it when he was in New York
and the comics are going to tonight's
show in New York and go I work out the
Improv here in New York like Klein or
those comics well then it shifted
immediately shifted that's why Leno went
right out to LA I know salt Freddie
Prinze go on The Tonight Show and say
I'm working at the Comedy Store and Leno
goes I got to get after the economy
store yeah and so that franchise didn't
start opening until the 80s like 84 when
Mark Anderson opened one in San Diego
then that started he started open up
this franchise did bud like Bud
franchised it out franchise yeah when he
saw the whole boom house that's way
that's when he made money that's when he
really made money Mark Anderson openes
clubs and bud was making you know it's
like the Trump thing I've heard a lot of
that stuff that says Trump on it they're
they're paying for the name for the name
yeah that's so bud was get like a gross
of every club I think I got answer
because like I you know you doing the
Tonight Show with Johnny Carson which
has to be the most nerve-racking huge
possible thing like he's leafless nights
and like yeah what year did you would
you first though 84 you did an 84 my god
yeah so you're gonna go on there I mean
just at that point it's it's it's what
that show like I I feel bad for young
people they don't understand how huge
that [ __ ] show was it was just like
it was it was everything every was the
Beatles on The Ed Sullivan it was it was
everything it was everything so you
they tell you you're getting the show so
you must be like over the moon excited
and then for me what immediately hit
would be the dread of like I'll [ __ ] now
I have to do this and I have to somehow
compartmentalize the [ __ ] terror of
this guy who can either invite me over
give me the okay or all of my peers are
gonna see that he didn't like me because
I everybody watch this [ __ ] everybody
watched it yeah so here's the deal how
it worked and correct me if I'm wrong
here he would give you what would he
would give you okay he'd call you either
call you over that was the highest
that's it or you got the okay so he's
still coming back right which is
accepted for the first time you but then
there was the one where he would just be
like no did we drumming his pencil on
the table I'll take his pencil and just
drumming and not looking at you and that
was like it man that was the worst and
he knew he was doing what he was doing
to the comic got that day yeah I read it
I read that book that his lawyer read I
mean yes look how ice-cold his mother
was like the ability to do that it's
like that's the trickle-down effect um
I'll tell you how I I dealt with doing
Letterman cuz Letterman was my Carson
like I literally had to I was so [ __ ]
like thinking what am I gonna do I had
to like work up like a healthy level of
hatred cuz that's just how I'm wired I'd
be like yeah [ __ ] this guy for make me
so [ __ ] him name was a great guy came
over he shook my hand and everything but
like I ate a little e be thinking [ __ ]
this guy and then to go out there so I
went out there and I had thank God I had
a great set and I remember like you see
it on TV and you think he's [ __ ] 80
yards this way and the band's 100 yards
they're all right they're like yeah you
could take two steps over and shake
Paul's hand another three you could
shake days I remember doing my set
hearing Dave laughs and it was such a
[ __ ] it was more relief there's like
oh my god he's laughing his eyes for
nameless you know you're actually
getting married so it was like in the
wheelhouse cuz he wasn't married or
anything like that it was just I just
might be thinking like I was so [ __ ]
relieved when it was over man just so
relieved so tell me what that was it but
sort of a Letterman Show
Letterman was always behind you on
camera so the audience could you were it
they were letting runs in the sight line
so they're looking at you and seeing
Letterman over your shoulder so if you
have Letterman laugh and
you could die oh wow yes so my time I
didn't they didn't have back then he was
already over at CBS I'm told by the NBC
show okay so anyway 84 I was in New York
because I left the Summer Olympics were
out here and I've said I'm gonna get out
of LA it's gonna be a mess and so
Kennison and I booked over to New York
for the summer mm-hmm and I was there
and I was working out in Jim McAuley The
Tonight Show booked her saw me in New
York and said and said you're ready man
want to do it in two weeks it was
awesome I need like two so you know did
you cobble this block people understand
it's a very unnatural set back then I
don't know how to do it now maybe they
just pull five minutes out of the
wrecked intact of five but you pull like
a greatest hits thing you broke from
this bit you put that's how I always
yeah and you cobbled together with these
weird segues right you know you're doing
a skiing water skiing joke than you know
when you come out of water your hair's
messed up you know when I get my hair
cut and yeah torturous speaking hair
horrible and so I I put this set
together you know that he helped me with
and then I'm practicing it every night
you know just going into clubs every
night there's many times I could run out
to Jersey gig coming back to him but
muttering it while you're brushing your
teeth the hope I could st. completely
freaking out and I was drinking and
doing a lot of blow back then so I was
like I gotta quit I go I gotta quit so a
week before I thought I'd just I'm not
gonna drink and do drugs were you high
when they told you you got the gig oh
yeah we went out to a bar after his
McCully and I went out to a bar when he
said you got it let's go talk about it
we went out to a bar drank and I didn't
do blow in front of him because I didn't
know whether he did it or not I wasn't
gonna risk that you know but we were
drinking yeah hell yeah and I got so
stressed out I got shingles I broke out
in shingles oh my god you know my my ass
and my leg would just blistered up and I
didn't know what the word I went through
the doctor said you got shingles man
know what yeah you got shingles that's
an old man's thing what do you stressed
out about something yeah yeah I'm doing
the tonight [ __ ] yeah then you probably
like what is it oh yeah you answer the
stress because now I know you're
watching and you're gonna be at home
going like wow yeah and so you're
standing backstage right so this is
Burbank obviously right where they shoot
at Burbank is the [ __ ] curtain was
iconic
and with that [ __ ] gold and blue and
weird ass all those weird colors all I
could think about was [ __ ] up I mean
literally I'm like going I can't [ __ ] up
you're not think about how much fun
you're gonna have yeah I didn't think
that this coming fun man right I earned
this yeah I deserve this I'm gonna go
out and go and have a good time and say
what's up Johnny you're not just like
yeah yeah did you have the panic thought
of whatever what if I forget where I am
what if I forget what I'm saying cuz it
didn't it didn't that happen to somebody
say happen to me or my HBO special I
blanked on my HBO special Oh God
for how long we ready to stop taping I
just went yeah I'm lost I'm lost
cuz it was again it was nav instead but
five minutes unnatural I could cobble
together a half hour out of like hours
of material and posted that you know
like just all together just cut and
paste cut and paste and I was practicing
that for a long time and I got out there
and I just went what am i doing what you
know it's like one of those things were
you gonna what the [ __ ] am i doing is it
was like Biff from Death of a Salesman
what happens that's yours bid here what
happens is you go out there and rather
than just doing a show you know you're
being watched and then you start
watching yourself and then you leave
yourself and then you're City and the
crowd going why is he moving his arm
like that cuz you're literally thinking
oh I'll dude we've all [ __ ] been yeah
so when you're standing behind that
curtain and you just just if adrenaline
was unbelievable it was unbelievable
then you walk out then you hit it and
then soon but it's like every other time
I mean I literally my mind went blank
like every time before I go onstage my
mind goes blank I gave you go what joke
a little what joke I don't have any
jokes I can't remember anything
yeah totally blank right and walk out
there do that first joke get the first
live and go yeah be locked in
yeah that first laugh and you're locked
in so you went out you did your first
joke yeah how did it do good laugh got a
good mind and and you know when you're
doing it you plan it everybody says the
first joke is just them seeing you and
hearing your for first time so don't
expect a big laugh so you don't put your
you know you know you that the I was
told and the three jokes in that's your
first killer joke right you know three
jokes and that should be your first kill
joke that's how you kind of planned it I
know they all right [ __ ] guys like
their ideas yeah fifth jokes should be
this oh great more [ __ ] to think about
it is unnatural it some night I know so
it was unnatural so you go out there and
you end up having had this really good
set have a really good set now you like
how long did it feel to look over at
Johnny like [ __ ] I'm gonna lock eyes
with this guy that looked over big smile
you don't big smiled a circle finger
like you said like big okay and I go
okay and I came backstage and Jim
McCauley greets me I gotta be your hands
be a great fantastic man to stand over
here standing here didn't just show you
stayin here and when Carson walks back
the way he walks back every after every
show this Ralph he takes backstage
you're gonna break down around he stops
shakes your hand that was great get a
photo-op phantom you can come back soon
ya got a picture you know you're a
picture and you just stand there going
okay and then he was fantastic moves on
right and you're like this is it then
you go back and the improv that night in
on Melrose and West uh you know West
Hollywood right everybody who's there
they turn the tv up everybody in the bar
standing there you're standing there
that's what kills me about how they
redid that now they got the bar upstairs
it's like all that history you guys all
those people had stood there watching
their friend's dad show said everybody
who leaned on that [ __ ] bar kills me
at least they didn't demolish and George
I used to say the same thing when a new
comic I'm glad you're in a good mood
tonight cuz we got a new comic coming on
right and the comics would mouth it and
and some would actually say it out loud
with Johnny that's how much everybody
knew that
wow that dad that routine right right
and you stand there and it's like yeah
how much blow did you do that night when
you get [ __ ] past that Jesus Christ
I had Coke in my pocket when I walked
out on the set that day like when you
watch run like [ __ ] Ron Burgundy and
all those [ __ ] movies that look more
like a documentary to you than rather
than a comedy it's like yeah we did all
that I had a suit like that I wore that
under Tonight Show I'd blow in my pocket
yeah wow man that's [ __ ] amazing well
we got a I got a run back to this I'm in
the middle of editing this [ __ ]
cartoon that's never gonna end do I got
to tell you man like this you've been
one I've ever had great guest but this
was just so [ __ ] I would be listening
as much fun as I did like I could ask
you a zillion
how do you not talk to a guy who [ __ ]
had coke in his pocket when he does the
[ __ ] Tonight Show you're like I'm
doing this either way this is either
gonna make me super happy or make me
want to [ __ ] kill myself so his book
is called kicking through the ashes my
life is a stand-up in the 1980s comedy
boom where can people get this Amazon
amazon.com amazon.com I'm gonna do Book
Soup assigning a book signing a book
super Hollywood January 6 January 6 7
o'clock January 6 and will do a signing
I tell some stories well you have any
coke in your pot filled with sugar it's
been such a pleasure man thanks so much
say this
my son is angry he can't be today he's a
huge fan huge and he is 17 years old he
is a Bangor man and he so digs you and
he was like oh dad man can I get out of
school can I just no can't do I wanna
he's of age come out to the club yes
reach out enough hopefully I'm still
funny at that place all right guys rich
shiner of a thank you so much for coming
on man all right all right here's a
little bit of advertising for you over
there all right loot crate give it a loo
be the envy of your friends and get your
100% exclusive crate at loot crate calm
slash bar and enter my codename
burrow to save $3.00 off on any new
subscription wait until I tell you about
December's crate it will have you fight
in the power room and loot crate offers
an epic range of pop-culture items for
less than 20 bucks a month if you're
more of a fanatical fashionista then try
loot where monthly wearables and
accessories with cult classics and your
favorite franchise if you want to get
fancy and get a bigger box with even
bigger loot there's loot crate DX want
to geek out your pet try loot pets they
got everything they got all of that [ __ ]
get ready for December's rebellious
themed revolution they've designed a
system to keep you down man and their
meddlesome hello friends it's time for a
revolution December December's crepe
features exclusive items from Assassin's
Creed mr. robot Firefly our monthly tea
shirt and pin and more including an
exclusive Funko pop your dad's Garage
Band Funko pop do not wait you have
until the 19th at 9 p.m. Pacific to
subscribe to for December's crate when
it's over it's over no more no more
crates go to loot crate calm / burn
enter my code Barbie you are are to save
$3 off on any new subscription today
alright lift everyone you know about
lift right it's the app it gets you ride
in minutes on-demand 24/7 for less than
the cost of a cab if you tried lyft you
know what I mean what with lyft you just
download the app request a driver and
they show up in three and a half minutes
on average that's really fast man every
lyft driver is fully vetted through that
ten point safety standard including
criminal India beep background checks
you know you'll get around quickly and
safely lyft drivers are rated after
every dried so only the best stick
around you don't have to worry about
getting into a filthy car with some
creepy dude with lifts you can tip in
the app which is obviously leads to a
happier drivers I mean nine out of ten
lyft riders rides get a perfect five
percent rate from the passenger it's
just a better all-around experience
bigger isn't always better
lyft isn't the biggest ride-sharing app
but it's the fastest growing in
highest-rated one I'm talking quality
over quantity thanks to lift you got an
easy way to avoid drunk driving you
never have to bum a ride and you never
have to worry about about parking a lot
of people are actually getting rid of
their cars is that true and relying on
lyft to get around now they're just
talking [ __ ] here and you know what I
don't evidently I don't blame them
according to the coffee right now lyft
is offering listeners a special deal get
three rides up to ten dollars each
that's a that's a $30 value if you can't
do basic math when you enter the promo
code billboard just download the free
lyft app today and enter the promo code
Bilborough in the payment section you'll
start with three free rides up to ten
dollars each that's a $30 value that's
promo code bill burr enter promo code
bill burr all right seat geek everybody
all the geeks with the seats buying
tickets online for sports and concerts
has been a confusing process for a long
time yeah you get ripped off it's not
confusing there's no confusion there
it's like why the [ __ ] does this cost so
much am i this far away from the goddamn
action it's always been hard to find the
best deal for the game that you want or
the show you want to go to and none of
none of these older ticket sites wanted
to change that but SeatGeek is different
they've come along with them and created
an amazing app and website that makes
it's easier than ever for fans to buy
and sell tickets everything about see
geeks is designed to make life easier
for sports and music fans see geek does
all the price comparisons for you by
searching multiple ticket sites and
ensuring that you get the best possible
deal see geek does all the work and you
save time and money best of all my
listeners get $20 off $20 rebate off
their first seat geek purchase to get
your $20 rebate on tickets now I'm
download the seat geek app go to the
settings tab on Jesus and click add a
promo code enter promo code bir c geek
will send you a $20 $20 after you've
made your first ticket purchase download
the seat geek app and enter the promo
code birth today be one of these [ __ ]
reads is over a minute let's try to blow
through this one here all right simply
safe ever find yourself almost all the
way to work or maybe you're out with
family and friends and you get that
nagging feeling did I close that door
why am I married to this person did I
lock that door you just don't have to
you you just don't know if you drive
yourself nuts thinking about that [ __ ]
well you don't have to worry about that
[ __ ] anymore cuz you got simply safe
home security
it's a nice extra layer of protection to
know simply safe is there simply safe
has an arsenal of sensors to protect
your entire home and keep your family
safe simply safe they just keep saying
the [ __ ] name here got rid of
everything that makes most home security
such a pain there's no long-term
contracts no hidden fees they won't
gouge you
it's just $14.99 a month that's three
times less than what other companies
charge and there's some big news simply
safe just released its brand new
high-definition security cameras this
camera is different it connects to your
security system it sends your smartphone
a video the second something happens hey
look at that [ __ ] [ __ ] breaking
into my house jerking off of my couch
you can see everything that's going on
as you're eating your [ __ ] souffle so
you won't have to wonder anymore
oh that's why my house is gonna be
trashed when I get home check out simply
safes new camera today just go to sin
we save bird calm right now that's
simply safe bird calm Hey
simply safe bird calm I was riding on
the Mayflower when I thought I spot some
land I yelled for captain e-rep I'll
have you understand who came a-runnin to
the deck said boys forget the whale
worth going over yonder cut the engines
change the sail on the bow line
all tough sailors do when they're far
away front seat
have yourself a merry little Christmas
let the Yuletide glow I don't know the
words but I'm gonna keep going here
playing patty-cake with some mistletoe
and a sleigh Santa Claus has an itchy
beard and big black boots sit in his lap
I don't know why I can't say Merry
Christmas somewhere along the line it
became offensive even though I don't
mean anything bad by it
what if some Mexican came up to you and
said happy Cinco DeMayo
would you say dude what the [ __ ] [ __ ]
it's all just April to me do-do-do-do-do
do-do-do-do-do friends it's that time of
year again boo boo boo boo boo when the
[ __ ] did you know say Merry Christmas
become offensive bah bah bah bah bah bah
boo boo boo you know I don't understand
that [ __ ] just because I say it you know
it's like if somebody Jewish said happy
Chanukah to me you know I wouldn't be
like you know what the [ __ ] dude you
know what the [ __ ] I don't understand
that I like saying Merry Christmas makes
me feel good it's so good right my chest
a little warm feeling just like the
Grinch you know when it's a little hot
and of broke out of that little box doo
doo doo doo
doo-doo-doo-doo this is all holiday
breakdown as I as I kick knowledge about
the holiday um whatever so have
yourselves a merry little Christmas he
is
I don't hate Muslims or Jews when I say
Merry Christmas
so whatever group he's walking around
saying it's offensive
go [ __ ] yourself in your [ __ ] [ __ ]
even if you're male you have a [ __ ]
because you've ruined part of my holiday
I would never do that to you all right
that's enough Jesus Christ all right you
know anyways how are you I know I'm
tone-deaf but you know I told you I was
going to break the holidays this year I
was at the airport coming back from
Vancouver listen to this week that I had
first of all this is the Monday morning
podcast
usually if I'm gonna sing badly I only
do it for a couple of seconds but uh you
know I know I just I kind of felt it and
I was just in Canada and they say Merry
Christmas up there which makes me feel
good because you know what that's what I
say you know do I have to go to Canada
nowaday listen to somebody say Merry
Christmas
I don't wanted to [ __ ] how big are
these groups I think you just need like
literally 18 people and they just you
know they just hold up signs and they go
what [ __ ] what [ __ ] and the way they
frame it on the news they make it look
like it's a zillion people you know you
know I don't know it's weird I'm trying
to think of whatever said Merry
Christmas just to a friend of mine who's
Jewish and he ever got offended I don't
think they ever did
so well so what 18 you and 18 your
friends get offended by the [ __ ] and
then you get to call yourselves a group
and then you get to start walking around
telling people what's offensive and what
isn't these are the holidays you [ __ ]
why don't you [ __ ] open your hearts to
another religion all right so anyways
[Music]
listen to this [ __ ] week that I had
alright you want to talk about busy
because my brain is going to be all over
the place I'm already telling you that
all right and I might even sing another
holiday [ __ ] song if I feel like it
hey Bill nobody saying you can't you
know I don't understand the hostility
why don't you relax okay you just got
back from the airport you haven't
showered yet you know you should have
taken a little bit of time showered you
know treated yourself and gotten
yourself in a mindset where you could
relax a little more and do a happier
podcast but you didn't you ordered a
grilled cheese sandwiches some chicken
noodle soup and you [ __ ] went right
in wearing the clothes that you've been
sitting in since last night at the
Canuck game and now you're laying on
your bed that's disgusting
anyways this is my week see what I did I
just talked myself down fought more
calmer tone like this this is the new me
so this isn't the new me this is the guy
I'm trying to be this is the person I
think I was before a bunch of [ __ ] up
[ __ ] happened to me and became me this
make me become like the screaming maniac
that I am so I'm trying to get back in
touch to me circa 1972 anyways um this
is my week Monday I saw I flew back from
New York City after a wonderful
engagement at Caroline's comedy club and
I landed I had a sandwich and then me
and three of my friends all went down to
the LA forum we saw ac/dc that was
Monday you know most people would call
it a [ __ ] week right there and be
like wow I just saw one of the most
legendary rock bands of all time
Brian Johnson's voice sounded
unbelievable he looked like he was
having the time of his life Angus was
still jumping around and I'm sick of
people on this tour going you
you know anger see you know he's great
but you know we kind of miss you know it
kind of he's kind of lost the step it's
like dude so of you I don't understand
how people feel like you know they look
at famous people like they're not
supposed to age you know and you know if
people [ __ ] video tapes you taking out
your trash seven years ago the last time
ac/dc was on tour I bet you don't have
such a big spring and you'll [ __ ] step
either start making fun Angus the guys
jumping around at 53 years of age never
missing a note try doing that at 16 try
doing the [ __ ] that he does I dare you
to try that on your [ __ ] your little
PlayStation game Guitar Hero you think
you could do that for an hour and a half
then do a striptease and moon the crowd
and then come right back in jump off a
[ __ ] drum riser and be right on the
[ __ ] one I don't think you could do
that leave Angus alone they were the
[ __ ] that was my Monday right and then
Tuesday
I began three straight 12-hour days
shooting my pilot for Comedy Central
which could not have gone better I think
we got a lot of [ __ ] hilarious stuff
I mean a very smart move I pulled the
Seinfeld I learned a lot from Jerry
Seinfeld you know he you know what did
he do one time I watched him we can
accept that accept an Emmy for his show
and he said something to the effect of
hi I'm Jerry Seinfeld and I am a bad
actor but I've proven if you surround
yourself with enough talent YouTube and
ba da Dada did it whatever so I went out
and tried to find the funniest [ __ ]
people I could so hopefully if I suck
the people around me are okay so that
was my Monday Tuesday Wednesday we
wrapped at about 9:00 p.m. Thursday
smoke the [ __ ] stogie as men do and
then I got my little Prius reeking of
Dutch masters and went home and the next
day I boarded a [ __ ] Air Canada
flight to Calgary and proceeded Friday
Saturday Sunday I went to a Calgary
flame
then in edmonton oilers aim and then a
vancouver Kentucky I always wanted to go
up there and I got a it was pretty
[ __ ] amazing and pretty goddamn cold
remember that [ __ ] when you were a kid
wherever the hell you lived like I might
not my nose has not stuck together when
inhaling since I went collecting on my
paper route and like the 5th grade
Calgary I don't know what the [ __ ] is in
Calgary okay let me do my little review
of the western part of Canada I write
Calgary first stop um I don't know I
can't tell I don't know what the [ __ ]
the deal was I didn't see a skyline it
was snowing like I haven't seen it's
snowing years and then I got on their
little [ __ ] trolley which was really
confusing and I went the wrong way like
seven times but the Saddledome was the
[ __ ] and I sat next to some guy from
Canada who said eh after everything you
know like that strange Bruce [ __ ] like
oh they got to get it out eh eh means
everything up there it means you know it
means like you know what I'm saying
it means what did you say it means huh I
guess that also means what he's I don't
know it's like seven different
it's like Donnie Brasco when he [ __ ]
explained uh forget about it that's what
a is in [ __ ] Alberta you got to get
it out eight and they all sound like
they almost sound like they're [ __ ]
Irish I don't talking about but the game
was great there was a shootout at the
end of the game eh and Panthers won that
one and then I the next [ __ ] day I
drove up to Edmonton through towns like
the town's out there I was looking at
the weather map it was like you know
[ __ ] Red Deer Yellowknife
you know those Indian names the classic
white guy thing you know you murder a
bunch of people you commit genocide and
then you name towns after them you know
did we destroy the wall the [ __ ] Ponca
Prague people let's name a street after
them maybe even a golf course I think
that that's only the right thing to do
considering none of them exist anymore
let's do something here to remember
these people after we've massacred them
and put small plot
it's on their phone in their sleeping
bags did Indians have sleeping bags I
don't think they did what did they use
for sleeping bags that they sleep in the
[ __ ] entrails of an animal like Luke
Skywalker
this podcast went off the rails about
[ __ ] two minutes ago because I got in
my head going did I just calm myself
down like five minutes ago and then all
of a sudden I stopped being funny I mean
his podcast started off great I sang
Christmas carols you know what I mean
I defended saying Merry Christmas you
know and then all this and I was like
wait a minute I'm coming off angry let's
take it down a little bit and then all
of a sudden I felt like I was doing the
traffic you know I like the traffic down
the south when you listen to it because
they still say when there's an accident
they call it a wreck it always makes me
feel like I'm watching NASCAR we've got
a wreck down there and I'm not a farm
they don't talk like that but that's all
I hear at that point when someone says
we got a wreck there's a car all pull up
on the side of the [ __ ] road
anyways they might drove up yeah I was
going to stop off in Red Deer to get
something to eat to eat just on my way
up to Edmonton just to say I [ __ ] did
it and then I was like you know what Red
Deer sounds like it reminds me of one of
those those AME murder mysteries that I
watched where these two hunters had gone
up to some [ __ ] place to go hunting
they stopped off in a bar they exchanged
words with people they got killed and
then somebody in the bar fed their
bodies to pigs and it was one of the
most creepiest [ __ ] stories I've ever
seen you know
just that whole [ __ ] feeding a person
to pigs and they all look like they were
in like Creedence Clearwater Revival's
so it was really [ __ ] with my head
and I don't know red deer just sounded
like that kind of [ __ ] could happen so I
bypassed it and I continued on up to
Edmonton I'm going to tell this story in
real time
let's fly for okay I had a great time
Edmonton was an awesome game coming up
there seeing all the championship
banners and the [ __ ] retired jerseys
at Gretzky and Messier and all you got
to do it okay
not to mention both the Saddledome and
Northlands Coliseum are
just basically I don't know they're like
no frills they made an ice rink and they
put seats around it and that's it
there's no uh none of that [ __ ] you know
I mean although you know what Calgary
definitely had the horse skating around
on the ice in between and oh god why do
I get the questions I just bored the
[ __ ] out of myself with it was such a
[ __ ] good time I had an awesome time
up there you know what it is I I just I
woke up at [ __ ] 8 in the morning and
I just got on a plane and I had to come
back and do the podcast so I'm skipping
over a bunch of good details you know
what did I say up day I saw some guy in
like - 90 million degrees Celsius
whatever the [ __ ] that is think that's
like five degrees American and he was
fixing a four-wheeler with no hat on
some end no gloves you stand out that do
you have ah Arthur Fonzarelli used to
dress when they gave him a garage when
they ran out of [ __ ] to do with this
character was before he became a teacher
but after him just hanging out at
Arnold's when they were finally like
okay this guy's like 30 he needs a job
you know I mean how does he afford to
live in that attic he was dressed like
that and it was [ __ ] cold out and he
was fixing a four-wheeler and I was I
actually videotaped it and if I knew how
to upload it I put it on there but
anyways just my podcast let me get to
the questions here people send me
questions all this week I think I shot
my load with that [ __ ] song right up
the front you know and if I sucked the
rest of the way out you got to admit
three minutes to Christmas Carolyn isn't
that am i defending my podcast I mean
this is ridiculous like I'm bombing as a
comedian
go come on man I was a funny joke so it
was funny you know I mean a this guy you
know I had a nice setup I didn't have
any extra words I disguised the
punchline I took a left at the last
second can't help look you guys don't
want to go alone for the right all right
question number one bill since you're
you're a struggling actor trying to make
it have you ever thought about doing gay
porn you know you guys have really been
[ __ ] lately but you know what I'm
going to go [ __ ] be a man about it
here okay let's go since you're a
struggling actor trying to make it have
you ever thought about doing gay porn to
make ends meet
you already have the iconic shaved head
and like hockey you have a shaved head
you like hockey
dick gay okay speaking of hockey Sean
Avery is underrated anyone who calls a
woman a [ __ ] and then tells her that he
wouldn't even I can't read your [ __ ]
typing he wouldn't come in her face
because she's too old is cool with me
all right let's get back to your first
question as I strongly have ever thought
about doing gay porn obviously know what
is the worst thing I have considered
doing I consider doing commercials back
when commercials weren't funny remember
back in the day like 1012 years 10 12
years ago they started to get funny but
it was that awkward middle ground where
you know you could be in a really funny
commercial or you could just be like
biting into a sandwich and then given
that look to the camera like boy oh boy
was that tasty you know I remember back
in the day like I refused to do a
commercial because I listened to that
Bill Hicks rant about that and then then
after a while I was like why am i making
a difficult business even harder you
know granted I don't go out for
commercial auditions but it's not
because I'm against doing commercials I
just don't do commercial auditions
because I'm lazy plus they're all the
way out in Santa Monica and I'm not
driving all the way over there to
[ __ ] act like I'm eating a bowl of
Froot Loops I'm not doing that you know
I do have a little pride all right
question number two bill hey I was
expand of the podcast I listened to most
of them traveling over Thanksgiving
break I did notice that you have a few
favorite words and since I lead a sad
pathetic life I thought it would be
funny to count them during last week's
podcast so here we go
okay evidently this is the list of my
favorite word's and how many times I say
them [ __ ]
three times wow that's pretty low we are
in a recession I don't know I said 27
times [ __ ] I said 42 times [ __ ]
I said 127 times Wow 127 times let's do
the math there that's about three times
a minute four times mmm
do what a half hour podcast Wow I'm the
Wayne Gretzky of the f-word all right
choke out a pheasant I say one time I
said one time okay
you're a Popeye Popeye like pop up up
chuckle to yourself nine times okay
unless I was interesting to anybody I
was kind of interesting to me that
somebody's that [ __ ] lonely
alright underrated overrated overrated
Brendan Fraser Oh underrated Brendan
Fraser Eric Lindros when he first came
into the league completely bald vagina
and college are overrated I would go
with you there the ball pagina is just
[ __ ] creepy
it's really [ __ ] creepy yeah not a
fan not a fan no I don't want to go down
to a fetched hot either scene I don't do
this [ __ ] I'm like I'm not taking in
this direction goddammit
alright three bill if you could have one
superpower what would it be also how
would you use it would you fight crime
would you commit crimes or would you
just use it to beat the [ __ ] out of
people who heckled you you know what I
would do I would use it to freak people
out who had power you know like if I was
like eh I can't just have one superpower
gonna have a couple like I put this way
if I was like Superman I could fly I
could I could see through you know walls
and I was bulletproof
I would I would yeah I would [ __ ] with
people who had power
I'm flying to the Oval Office you know
right in the middle and talking about
[ __ ] you know I'll just be standing
outside the window you know just stare
down like Michael Myers and like
Halloween I would just do that I would
just freak people the [ __ ] out I
wouldn't use it to fight crime I would
use it to get to my gigs a little
quicker rather than flying Southwest and
I would just wear my superhero outfit
the whole week you know like Steve
Martin you know it was where that white
suit I would just wear whatever my
superhero [ __ ] suit was and I just
fly to my gigs and then I fly home no
security no [ __ ] bags
I'd have a little toothbrush in my
utility belt what would I do with my I
don't know what I would do with it
I would [ __ ] with corporations and and
leaders of the world and all my
information would be [ __ ] that I read on
YouTube and Wikipedia and yeah that's
what I would do um Wow no [ __ ] energy
this week or as long as me I was so
excited about this podcast and I just
really feel like this is uh Bilborough
woefully miscast in the Monday morning
podcast number six bill I was wondering
if there are any situations that you
steer away from when you work audiences
I'm not talking about something as
profound as a racial observation but any
social subjects that crowds really don't
respond to or is everything up for grabs
as okay these are two things I don't
really do sex sex material I just feel
like the crowd absolutely loses their
mind if you talk about sex no matter
what you're saying and I got a minute I
always feel a little crude what I'm
talking about it you know even that's
why I kind of broke off the whole ball
bagina think it's just kids it's no
class you know I don't know it's just
crude unless you have some really unique
[ __ ] story to tell you know I'm not
like a prude or anything but a lot of
times like when I go to see movies and
you know two actors that are having a
love scene that some guy sucking on the
girls titties it's it's ridiculous to me
and I always look at the person like
that that's not even necessary to moving
this story along you know back in the
day they would just show the couple go
in the room and they would close the
door and then they would just play that
saxophone because the sax always back in
the day always meant someone was going
to some but people were [ __ ] that's
what the saxophone meant either meant
that or someone was going to do with
striptease and he had to play with that
really [ __ ] bland [ __ ] sound and
everybody knew that somebody was getting
some dick right but you didn't have to
show it you know that was my whole thing
with like Brokeback Mountain I don't
look mind watching a movie about a
couple of gay cowboys but I don't know
how much a couple dudes [ __ ] a tent
you know and I don't understand that
then like what that makes me more
comfortable with my sexuality because I
look at that I got
omit half the time there's two things
that really gross me out in movies it's
like over-the-top kissing is [ __ ]
gross to me and act people who eat
during scenes I don't even I have
probably talked about this is my number
one pet peeve in a movie like I've gone
out to lunch with people and they're
eating and they talk and they take their
moments when to do it
something about actors the second
they're in a movie and they start eating
they start overacting eating you know
they start [ __ ] pointing with breath
yeah oh you know god [ __ ] dude let me
get [ __ ] hanging out of their mouths
it's like dude why don't you finish what
you're eating collect your [ __ ]
thoughts swallow and then present your
line okay I don't need you [ __ ] sorry
I don't know what the [ __ ] I'm talking
about now this too subject okay so sex
and um I don't make fun of the mentally
handicapped
I just don't it just crosses the line
I've done it before in the Opie and
Anthony show I've piled on I definitely
said some [ __ ] on stage if it just pops
into my head but generally speaking I
don't write bits I just don't you know
half of it because I think you know it's
just brutal to me and then secondly I
haven't had any kids yet and I really
feel like I'm jinxing myself a long time
ago I did do comic view and I did do a
bit about movies about the mentally
handicapped I don't know if you can find
that on YouTube and my parents saw it
and they weren't happy and I'm still
looking for approval so I took that too
about this too many details I'd yeah
those are the two subjects I really
don't I don't do [ __ ] like that
and I also try not to do stuff that will
reinforce moronic thought you know as
far as like a racial [ __ ] I try not to
do that but everything else yeah I don't
care other than I really enjoy pissing
people off in the crowd you know like
whatever whatever group I was today back
if that Merry Christmas group you know
the people who find that offensive we're
at my show like you know it would just
basically be your duty as a comedian to
just make their night as miserable as
[ __ ] possible so I'm definitely an
[ __ ] but yeah those are the sex sex
and the [ __ ] right there there you
go those are those are the lines all
right number eight bill do you fish no I
don't occasionally I have I've gone
fishing but now I don't own a rod or a
real my favorite part of it is going out
on the boat and hoping to see I like
looking at wildlife I don't like killing
it you know even if they fish it just
[ __ ] bothers me like you know there's
already dead fish in the supermarket why
don't just eat that but then I read all
the survival stuff like I should know
how to do this but then you go out
deep-sea fishing and they [ __ ] do
everything for you you just sit down
they're like and your rod and reel sir
they just hand it to you they tell you
what to do they know where to go where
the fish are and it's like you know you
feel like I feel like you know when
you're like 5 years old your dad let you
sit in his lap and steer the [ __ ] car
and you're like Grover the car no you're
not no you're not your [ __ ] child and
I also really enjoy the drinking that's
the part of the fishing that I like even
though booze and boats don't miss mix
according to the posters all right bill
who do you think are the top three
electrical guitarists that are currently
performing I have no [ __ ] idea I'm 40
years old
I shouldn't know that all right my
favorites of all time are Stevie Ray
Vaughan and recently I really got back
into Jimmy Page I really got back into
his [ __ ] and I don't know who the third
one is take your pick but it's
definitely I don't like the Steve Vai
Joe Satriani kind of guys those guys who
can play really fast but it sounds like
they're playing on a Casio keyboard
I'm not into really fast guys I'm into
those guys know those you know those
guys guys to give you chills speaking of
which the best part that's what I wanted
to the best part of the [ __ ] hockey
trip that I took was when I went to
Vancouver and they saying Oh Canada and
the guy comes out he sings the first
verse or whatever and then he stops and
then he just sort of conducts the crowd
as they sang the second half I got
literally goosebumps listening to the
people up in Vancouver singing o Canada
because I never heard it sung like that
you know people in America at the hockey
game sing o Canada the way they sing the
[ __ ] national American national
anthem and Canada there's no passion you
know give a [ __ ] you know you should
have heard of singing they were like oh
say can you see and then they get to
this song they're just like oh oh they
[ __ ] you know milk in every note
they're into it
Gloria sent free alright enough singing
here alright bill number nine at
Caroline's the Caroline show you
mentioned that your grandmother is 101
years old
at her age does she still have any
messed up out-of-date reasonings my
grandfather is 86 he's typical old
Italian man sharp for his age but
recently an interracial couple moved
next door to him and we had to stop him
from going to City Hall because he
wanted to have his property taxes lower
due to the fact as he put it a colored
woman is living next door
swear to God that's true no [ __ ]
what do you think [ __ ] up [ __ ]
classic or a little both that's a hard
one obviously somebody you know below
the age of 60 thinks something like that
yeah that's [ __ ] up but I mean the
guy's [ __ ] let's let's do the math
Avery's 86 years old
alright let's how do we do this here
eighty six plus four is ninety four
years from now is 2012 so he was born in
alright the guy's born in nineteen
[ __ ] twenty-two alright he's eighteen
in 1940 they didn't even let black
people in the [ __ ] army and when they
did they put him in a special unit it's
like [ __ ] 15 years before when the
[ __ ] was civil rights no it was like 25
[ __ ] years after that 23 yeah no I
mean that's calle that's his wheelhouse
you know i mean the same way i don't
know
like what the best guitarists are that
are playing today because now I'm 40 I'm
off like you just your weight you get
you shoved off to see I got my [ __ ]
ten albums in my head then I'm going to
listen to for the rest of my life the
same way old people still listen to in
the mood
dead dead dead did they [ __ ] love
that song I hate that song
drives me nuts makes me want to kill
somebody but when I'm 80 I'll still be
listening to back in black and I think
you take how you think along with you so
I don't know and at that point he's 86
is he really going to start a hate group
you know it's kind of funny
racism becomes funny only when you're so
[ __ ] old that you couldn't do
anything about it
you know then you just become this crazy
old guy who's just saying a bunch of
[ __ ] so I guess yeah it is that is funny
that is funny but you know it's weird
this is getting back to the what that
kid was asking me about what you talk
about right now I feel like I have a
social responsibility because I'm
talking to 14 people over the goddamn
phone to now say that that's [ __ ] up
okay you know what in public on
television if the guy did that that's
definitely [ __ ] up but sitting in your
living room and your grandparent says
something [ __ ] racist it's hilarious
you know not because you condone it just
because they're so uncensored they don't
give a [ __ ] and yeah I probably would
have left I would've left I'm not saying
I'm condoning it on any level alright
question of a 10 I know it's really
really overrated over it under a this
assumption that all gay men are funny
you know what that's just hilarious
right there because you really do
picture them like that I've actually
said that difensa gave people like I
understand why people have such a
problem with them you know the [ __ ]
hilarious and exactly you know I don't
want to watch two of them [ __ ] a tent
you know I have my but this guy says
basically I work in a restaurant we ever
shared gay guys that have a great sense
of humor but just because you're gay
doesn't mean describing what you'd let
Clive Owen do to you in great detail is
funny yeah that's kind of nasty I've
known a couple gay guys who get a little
over-the-top with the [ __ ]
description of their sexual [ __ ] that
they want to do you know
yeah that does get creepy you know but
you know what it is that's Karma for
straight guys because how that makes you
feel as a straight guy that's how women
feel when you when you know some girl
walks by oh my god the plug-in mineral
or you know whatever [ __ ] evil [ __ ]
you say so yeah
wow that's a lot of awful images in my
head alright let's get the next one
overrated cable TV especially the movie
channels because they just rerun all the
same suck ass movies like Kim to get
Kindergarten Cop are under siege they
still run van Damme movies and the worst
are the cheesy pornos yeah you know what
I gotta admit the only reason why I
watch [ __ ] movie TV is just to watch
the fights and I watch that show Dexter
is anybody even still listening to this
podcast I'm so [ __ ] jet lag right now
from flying to seeing three hockey games
and three nights I think I feel like I'm
just I'm reading like the [ __ ] stock
report all right underrated all this
should wake you up the sex swing the sex
swing is underrated really I didn't know
people were out there god I think
[ __ ] blows or maybe you're saying
it's underrated because no one really
talks about it okay let's hear the
review the sex swing really I'm not
trying to be scandalous or anything if
this is something people have not yet
tried for Christ's sake try it I promise
it makes it fun and easy to [ __ ] yes
because the rest of us find it tedious
and not fun you know what that's the way
you should you know what I think that
that's a the sex swing should be for old
people get viagra and they still want to
[ __ ] alright
oh well I just said it wasn't a new sex
material but you really just [ __ ] you
know he's [ __ ] lobbed it over than
that okay this is what you do okay you
[ __ ] Lube up grandma all right not
grandma your wife now it's really
disgusting all right you [ __ ] take a
little hit sigh agri and then you just
push her away like you just would you
like a little kid you push away just
keeps coming to you ah then you just
push your wing it
oh honey right
you [ __ ] bag away anyone else what if
you impregnate her you know share you'll
be dead by the time the kids [ __ ] in
kindergarten but you know you you'll
[ __ ] be a good day America they think
you're they act like it was cute like
when Tony Randall had a kid at 72 know
that Tony that Tony [ __ ] Randall you
know if you have a kid at 72 you know
especially if it's a boy what you
basically just had is a future felon
alright because the [ __ ] confusion of
having a 72 year old gay man as your dad
who dies when you're in the fourth grade
you know at the very least you know
you're gonna rob a convenience store I
don't know that is that Yugi I was just
that was really out those of it was an
[ __ ] move on his part and I've never
been able to enjoy the odd couple the
way I used to uhm alright alright
overrated I like this one this is a
great one song for this is overrated
songs for causes you know those hacky
collaborations with a bunch of stars in
the same studio you're a singer
leave the life-and-death [ __ ] to someone
else alright that's sort of a two part
thing there I I hate songs for causes I
didn't mind the we are the world kind of
[ __ ] just because that actually seemed
like there were so many people involved
that no one really got the credit but
like you know when when all those
rednecks were making those let's go to
war song songs and protect the boys
those songs were really really [ __ ]
cheesy what was that one and Uncle Sam's
gonna put a boot in your ass or whatever
the [ __ ] that one that was just really
one of the most ignorant songs I think
I've ever heard
and impress you know like who the [ __ ]
is not going to like a song that says
you know support the troops and let's go
[ __ ] up some people
um I can save always done that right the
Bogle boogie Woogie Bugle Boy remember
that Ababa David Abba David a Batman
alright um and you said you're a singer
leave the life-and-death [ __ ] to someone
else I disagree with that I don't think
just because you're in the public eye
therefore you shouldn't talk about who
you vote for or you shouldn't have
opinions all right
be honest with yourself all right the
this every bar you walk into these
people talk in politics they're talking
life and death [ __ ] people sitting there
going dude you know we should do you
know we should do right
some [ __ ] [ __ ] down the end of the
bar you listening to him you'll actually
[ __ ] wait till he's finished you'll
never call him a [ __ ] then all of a
sudden you have a [ __ ] hit song and
you don't want to hear somebody talking
about it you know what it is this is
what it is
I should just said this is what it is
rather than go you know what it is all
right like you could actually respond to
me
it's the fact it's very hard to do stuff
like that without coming off as preachy
and that's another thing in my act that
I try to never do I never used the word
we
because I saw a comedian do it one time
and it annoyed the [ __ ] I mean he was
like do we do this now we want a country
where we blah blah blah I mean it was
like dude I want to [ __ ] choke you
with the mic court God's the references
I just don't fly now you know this
really is a train wreck this is like
what was that what was that [ __ ]
album that that dude that nut from the
Beach Boys never put out was it called a
[ __ ] nut Pet Sounds if fun they
finally just put it out when he was just
going nuts this is my podcast version of
this song or that let George Michael one
where he's just like I'm not going to be
in the videos darling I'm just going to
put other people in and I want the music
to stand on itself and then his career
just takes a [ __ ] nosedive it's like
listen listen okay even gayer Tom Cruise
if you're not do not [ __ ] we're
shaking your ass in the TV with your
little [ __ ] stupid little scruff
going nobody gives a [ __ ] you know I
know I didn't give a [ __ ] as much I was
like if I couldn't see George Michael's
asked
he was I was a very confusing artist for
me because I really liked how he sang on
some songs like when he redid that Elton
John song he [ __ ] destroyed it but he
was just so [ __ ] effeminate it just
made me uncomfortable you know if he
just said listen I'm gay and I just got
done blowing somebody and I'd really
love to do it again
that would destroy the tension anybody
okay he's out in the open then he can
laugh about it you know he did I just
blow somebody and I was singing a song
my guy but it's a fact that he doesn't
bring it up and now he's singing in
occasionally you know he does a little
[ __ ] Twinkle Toes move it just makes
it [ __ ] uncomfortable and very hard
to enjoy the music alright another thing
that is underrated a good waiter and/or
bartender just some guys really good at
his job especially when you don't have
to ask him for anything and he's right
on top of it absolutely
like the [ __ ] waiters in the
bartenders over at Smith and Wollensky
you ever want to go there and have a
[ __ ] professional weight or slash
bartender I told you guys I was over
there Lazarus is [ __ ] great you felt
like a god to him
telling you early in the rat pack
everybody was dressed nice get married
let people know you're not a homo
Thanksgiving is overrated a day involved
with nothing but gorging yourself and
watching High School in pro football
junk food rest breakfast cereals
overrated I don't know about you but a
bowl of Fruity Pebbles are cool Cookie
Crisp is just as good when you first
wake up as when you're shit-faced you
know what I got to agree with you but I
would definitely go with fruity pebbles
cookie crisp and Captain Crunch you know
as much as I like them as a kid do you
ever get a mouth full of those things
and you when you bite down there's like
three of them one of them just one of
them turned sideways on your tongue and
it misses your teeth and it hits the
roof of your mouth I mean dude that is a
[ __ ] pain like I mean in Guantanamo
they should do that they should [ __ ]
put [ __ ] Coco Crisp on [ __ ]
people's tongues and make them bite down
you get all the information you want I
don't like those series I don't like
serials that you know or they get on the
outs
idea teeth and they go right up in
between you know that that skin that
covers your teeth whatever that's I
guess that's called your face yeah it
gets gets underneath that you know it
just [ __ ] drives it in there and then
that night you forget that you did it
then your brushing your teeth and of
course the toothbrush goes off your
teeth and goes right into that raw
[ __ ] place I don't like those serious
Fruity Pebbles I like well so I like you
know Fruity Pebbles one a few ones I
don't get that [ __ ] crazy with
breakfast series I like that likes
classics Cheerios Raisin Bran great nut
flakes
I like great nuts you know and I know
you think oh those things are so
granulated they can't cut up your
[ __ ] mouth I really have to end this
podcast I get apologize you guys one of
the worst podcast I've had I've just you
know probably nine times during this
podcast have literally just kind of come
to feeling like I passed out for three
minutes and I know I continued talking
so I apologize for any for any sort of I
can't even talk listen me I said any for
tough and said any sort of alright here
we go let's get let's let's wrap this up
bill and get on with it okay
another thing overrated a dude who has
the balls to wear fur that is [ __ ]
hilarious
all right here's a story I saw a guy the
other day wearing a full-length raccoon
coat and it looks so [ __ ] bad-ass and
the best part was that he also had the
Fox head scarf to go with it
maybe want to get one of my own you know
what that's [ __ ] hilarious there's
not enough people out to address like
fur trappers you know that's also you
know because that's but that's one of
those things like Merry Christmas now
it's just become taboo to wear fur which
you know I wouldn't wear fur but uh you
know I would never you know spray
ketchup at somebody who was wearing if I
always said pheasant I almost said a
pheasant that really is my default
animal isn't it
god damnit you know what whoever wrote
that in you got me you got one of my
ticks we were playing poker you'd know
exactly what my hand was um all right
one more overrated underrated Sidney
Crosby of the Pittsburgh Penguins and
is overrated his hype of being the next
one in hockey I'm so [ __ ] sick and
tired of hearing this Alby --it it's
died down the past year hearing that
he's the next crest I'm sick of hearing
that he's next the next Gretzky he's not
yeah well I mean that's kind of like
that's not his fault dude that's because
everyone wants someone to be the next
Gretzky you know he's not writing the
articles that's like after Michael
Jordan retired there was a nice you know
there's always going to be that hangover
saying someone's going to be the next
[ __ ] Jordan because you want to see
it and I didn't going to happen and I
think that fits some quick ones
underrated overrated underrated vinyl
overrated the compact disc
I think compact discs are underrated you
know all you people going out there just
get your music digitally and then what
happens you [ __ ] iPod dies and you
lose your entire collection I've talked
about this
you want to comp having a compact disc
is like having the gold behind your
paper money all right you need to backup
your digital [ __ ] because it's not worth
anything compact discs are tangible you
have them vinyl definitely underrated it
definitely gets hot and sticky and the
Sun but if you spill some it's very easy
to clean and that's it that's the Monday
morning podcast for this week I really
apologize for being so [ __ ] jet lag I
hope I can get some sort of points for
getting right off the goddamn plane and
you know go in the pod Jesus crisis to
me just babbling like a [ __ ] old
woman all right here we here we go what
do I have to hide here I'm literally
taking off my hooded sweatshirt
that's how right in the door I was when
I [ __ ] started doing this podcast I
am going to be I'm going to be let me
get on the [ __ ] website here if
you're still hanging in here I really
should send you some sort of a gift
would you like to hear another holiday
song as i func in the I don't know the
words you know you know my [ __ ]
holiday song I hate the most is silver
bells
it's just some about the temple of that
song just sucks the life out of a lower
half of my body and I just have to you
know it always comes on when I'm in the
mall and I really just don't want to
shop anymore and it just comes on silver
those silver valve is rude that one and
I don't like Jingle Bell Rock I hate any
sort of jazzing up jingle bell jingle
bell Jingle Bell Rock jingle bell time
yeah I [ __ ] hate that song and I hate
that Michael Jack Jackson Santa Claus is
coming to town I hate the way he phrases
it and I know making fun of a [ __ ]
seven-year-old and I should just be
happy that he was able to go into the
studio and perform that day but I did
shut the [ __ ] just shut up Michael the
seven-year-old you please just shut the
[ __ ] up I hate that song I really hate
that song
I like the classic slower ones the Bing
Crosby ones does anybody care all right
I'm on my website ah when he got here
all right I'm in January I'm taking a
break until January all right uh January
8th I'm already back out on the road
wait what's today the 15th there's 16
more days 16 all right I get three weeks
off [ __ ] my bitching about choices
people out there churning butter all
right I'm gonna be at the improv in
Tampa Florida
January 8th 9th and 10th and I haven't
been there in a long [ __ ] time and
that they'd scaring the [ __ ] out of me
because Florida is it's a crazy animal
man I don't know what to do with it I
don't know how to sell tickets in
Florida all right I've gone down there
I've done what I can [ __ ] do and all
right now people run the country
likewise peaking in that redneck [ __ ]
southern voice you talking about Florida
Florida isn't part of the south yes it
is yes it is if you get out of Miami
that entire that entire state is is you
know you could film
a 400 seasons of cops Dog the Bounty
Hunter and if you ever really you know
look at Dexter Dexter is [ __ ] taped
down there right isn't it Miami Vice
buddy my told me that what do what do
they have on those t-shirts down there
Florida what do they call it a cool
place for shady people something like
that hot place for shady people it's one
of those play on words I'm not good at
that [ __ ] alright I'm going to be at The
Improv time in Tampa on January 8th 9th
and 10th and oh and January 8th is the
show your tits show just to let you know
that's something new that that's nothing
to do with me you know I'm actually
against it I don't want girls to show me
the titties during my show you know but
you know something that The Improv czar
coming up with you know I think it's
sexist but you know I don't want to
cause any static so you know just know
that when you're showing me your tits
during that show that you know there
wasn't my call I don't condone it but I
was powerless to stop it so you know
yeah I guess I'll go along with it I'll
sign some titties after the show you
know show me a thong in whatever it is I
mean I'm just there for the art you know
okay uh and then after that I'm going to
be happy improv in Houston Texas
January 22nd 23rd and 24th I'm really
excited to go back to that one because
I'm actually going to hit this guitar
store out there called southpaw guitars
they have nothing but left-handed
guitars there and I'm going to go there
and spend some money [ __ ]
and after that and we at the Wilbur
theater in Boston and the comedy
connection in Chicopee Massachusetts
February 6 through the 7th and that is
it Wow
47 minute podcast that's how [ __ ] jet
lag that was I knew I just fell asleep
for like 10 minutes in the middle that I
apologize this is way too [ __ ] long
everybody have a Merry Christmas ok now
I mean that the nice way have a Merry
Christmas even if you're not [ __ ]
celebrating Christmas have a [ __ ]
Merry Christmas goddammit it's not a bad
thing it's unreal
so I'm [ __ ] real
how did that become bad I don't know
bill why don't you [ __ ] analyze it
for another 47 minutes all right I'm out
of here
god bless all yeah I'll talk to you next
Monday have a great week okay this comes
down the street crazy
and throws us all in jail for carrying
hot food
yeah bust it up don't even ask me how I
went to get some help I walk by a
Guernsey cow who directed me down to the
Bowery slums where people carried signs
same band above I realized right away
acid I hope that I'm not late when I
realized I haven't even talked to five
these scream I went into your restaurant
looking father cooking I've told him I
was the editor of a famous a to keep
book the waitress he was handsome he
wore a powder blue cape I ordered some
Suzette I said could you please make
that cream guess they're low kitchen
exploded from boiling fat it was flying
everywhere I left without my hat
I didn't mean to be nosy but I went into
it banking to get some feel free rap and
all the boys back in the tank they asked
me for collateral I pull down my pants
they threw me
comes this girl from France who invited
me to her house I went but she had a
friend who knocked me out and love my
boots and I was on the street again
[Music]
then I rapped upon a house with a US
flag upon display I said could you help
me out I got some friends down the way
the man says get out of here I'll tear
you limb from limb I said you know they
refuse Jesus team you said you're not
him get out of here before I break your
bones ain't your pop I decided to have
him arrested and I went looking for car
[Music]
well I ran outside and I hopped inside
cab I went out the other door this
Englishman said father as he saw me leap
a hotdog stand and a cheery if it stood
park across from a building advertising
brother
I ran right through the front door like
a hobo
sailor des but it was just the funeral
parlor and the masked man who I was I
repeated that my friends were all in
jail with a sigh he gave me his card he
said call me and plead I I shook his
hand and said goodbye and ran out to the
street when a bowling ball came down the
road and knocked me off my feet the pay
phone was ringing it's just about
through my mind when I picked it up and
said hello
if [ __ ] through the line
[Music]
by this time I was fed up they're trying
to make it stab at bringing back some
help for my friends and captain e-rep I
decided to flip a coin by either heads
or tails
wouldn't let me know if I should go back
to the shipper back to jail so I locked
my sealer suit my god a coin to flip it
came up tails around mercy
back in the ship well I got back into
the parking ticket off the mast I was
ripping it to shreds when his Coast
Guard boat went past they asked me my
name
and I fit Captain Kidd they believe me
but they wanted to know what exactly
that I did I sit for the Pope Bobby
route I was employed they let me go
right away they're paranoid
[Music]
well the last I heard of a rap he was
stuck on a wheel that was married to the
deputy sheriff raga jail but the
funniest thing was when I was leading
the babe I spied three ships sailing and
they are all coming my way I asked the
captain what his name was and how come
he didn't drive a truck he says name was
Columbus how do you say good luck
[Music]
you